president biden travels to new york city
today to meet with the mayor eric adams
amid a spike in violent crime thousands
of nypd officers and employees
filled the streets wednesday for the
funeral of officer wilbert mora he and
his partner were both shot and killed
last month while responding to a call
nationwide that makes five officers
killed by gunfire this year and 30
wounded and that's on pace for a very
sharp increase from just two years ago
jeff begaye shows us that dangerous guns
are easier than ever for the criminals
to get their hands on
at this atf firing range in virginia
we watched as a legal semi-automatic
handgun was converted into an illegal
machine gun in a matter of seconds
capable of firing off more than 30
rounds almost instantaneously today you
can manufacture that little conversion
device on your kitchen table in a 3d
printer atf acting director marvin
richardson says technology is partially
to blame for the recent rise in gun
related crime technology has allowed us
to be able to
take a firearm and reduce it to a box of
parts that isn't necessarily covered by
the federal firearms laws you've got
different platforms that allow you to
order it from the privacy of your home
have it delivered to your front door
it's almost a perfect storm so how does
the atf counter that
remember the the gun control act 1968 is
54 years old
the national firearms act of 1934 is 88
years old so those you're saying laws
you're saying the laws on the books are
outdated no i think that the actual
dates of the statute's enactments would
say that
increasingly the atf says these modified
weapons along with homemade so-called
ghost guns are leaving law enforcement
out gunned how many guns do you have in
here about 15 thousand
acting deputy director thomas chittim
showed us the reference library atf uses
for its investigations but guns
assembled built or modified at home are
almost impossible to track we haven't
seen so many machine guns used in crimes
since prohibition is that right that is
right your average law enforcement
officer is not armed with a machine gun
increasingly criminals are with just
over 2 500 special agents and a budget
that has remained relatively flat in
recent years richardson has this message
we really have to work together
communities law enforcement our elected
officials everyone has to work together
to become a part of the solution to this
problem just this morning the justice
department launched a new initiative
making it a priority for prosecutors to
bring federal charges against suspects
who use ghost guns and during our taping
and after frankly i was asked numerous
times if firing a ghost gun feels any
different than firing a manufactured gun
and to me it didn't but what really
surprised me was how easy that
conversion device turns
a ghost gun into a machine gun
very very eye-opening jeff uh and it'll
be an open question whether congress
acts particularly since so many law
enforcement are at the wrong end of
those ghost guns uh when they get out in
the public thank you very much